el mundo está lleno de datos cada
aplicación que usas está llena de datos
en cadena de mi alma cenamos datos sobre
usuarios insignias y el progreso en
facebook almacenan datos acerca de quién
eres quiénes son tus amigos lo que están
publicando en el banco de américa
almacenan datos acerca de cuánto dinero
tienes y en qué cuentas está cómo
almacenan datos esas aplicaciones bueno
ellos usan una base de datos que es un
programa que ayuda almacenar datos y
proporciona funcionalidad para añadir
modificar y consultar esos datos y hace
todo eso muy rápido las bases de datos
tienen muchas formas pero el tipo más
popular de base de datos se llama base
de datos relacional almacena cada tipo
de información en una tabla algo así
como guardar datos en una hoja de
cálculo un renglón representa un
elemento y una columna representa
propiedades sobre ese elemento por
ejemplo para almacenar datos sobre los
usuarios de khan academy tenemos una
tabla de usuarios con un renglón para
cada usuario y columnas para las
propiedades como alias y ubicación las
bases de datos relacionales forman
relaciones entre las tablas
particularmente fácil por ejemplo con el
fin de almacenar usuarios de khan
academy y sus insignias
podríamos tener una tabla de usuarios y
una tabla de insignias y una tabla de
usuarios insignias para recordar qué
usuario ganó qué insignias solo por
relacionar el aire del usuario con el
aire de las insignias esa es una manera
más eficiente de almacenar que tener que
repetir todo acerca del usuario y todo
sobre las insignias en una tabla de
usuario insignias la mayoría de las
bases de datos tienen un lenguaje de
consulta para interactuar con la base de
datos sql es un lenguaje diseñado
especialmente para el exceso a base de
datos y es el más popular con sql
podemos crear tablas cambiar datos
consultar datos que nos interesan como
si quisiéramos saber qué usuarios se
unieron la semana pasada o qué usuarios
tienen una insignia en particular eso es
lo que vamos a enseñar aquí realmente
vas a probar sql aquí en el navegador
usando esquiú light una implementación
particular de sql no vas a poder
escribir toda la aplicación aquí pero
cuando hayas aprendido sql vas a
entender mucho mejor cómo se almacenan
los datos en las aplicaciones que usas y
podrás usar sql si programas una
aplicación